ich habe auf jeden fall folgendes
produkt bestellt und zwar eine überholte
sony ca 12 16 ab playstation mit 500
gigabyte wurden das passwort ist
[Musik]
69 hey was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video karate
ich hoffe natürlich jedes gut ich freue
mich heute sehr der nächsten fahrt zu
den reflex zu machen
ich hatte es im letzten video schon
angekündigt dass ich auch eine ps4
bestellen würde und ich hatte das auch
schon gemacht ich weiß es kommt jetzt
weiter auf die play station 5 raus aber
ich hatte noch so ein bisschen ruhiger
und dann konnte ich mir da noch einer
play sie ziehen wir haben ja vor einer
woche angefangen mit dem rief erwischt
iphone
das war ein iphone 4s an sich absolut
okay ich glaube das hat nicht mal 30
euro kostet wenn ihr das video noch
nicht gesehen habe zeigt dass auf jeden
fall gerne ab ach so genau und das
wollte ich unter den kommentaren
verlosen leute ich blende der
letztjährige gewinner ein
so richtig raus du hast gewonnen und ich
kontaktiere ich dann oder wenn du das
siehst kannst du mich auch kontaktieren
dann kriegst du das geniale iphone 4s
könnte
heute wird sind aber auf jeden fall noch
ein bisschen leiser und auch ein
bisschen teuer war das muss man ganz
klar sagen wir haben hier nämlich ich
zeige es euch mal ich habe auf jeden
fall folgen das produkt bestellt und
zwar eine überholte sony ca 12 16 ab
playstation mit 500 gb in schwarz für
185 euro ist jetzt hier schon
ausverkauft also 70 mehr des item street
racing center bandelt james may or may
not be ok alles klar kein plan ich habe
die kurz nachdem ich das iphone gestellt
habt noch nachbestellt und ja irgendwie
sind die alles ort out also gibt's gar
nicht mehr was auf jeden
jetzt zu sagen wir haben ja hier nicht
die playstation 4 slim sondern die von
2015 meine ich ist rausgekommen ich will
jetzt auch nichts falsches sagen aber
ich meine die playstation 4 2014
rausgekommen und 2015 wurde dann noch
mal überarbeitet und das modell müssen
von 2015 sein ich würde es auf jeden
fall uns vorher nochmal nach also 2014
gegen die playstation 4 offenen markt
2015 mutti dann leicht abgeändert und
das kam die ps4 slim dazu die 300 gramm
leichter ist und aber kein 4k
unterstützt und 2017 kamen dann die ps4
pro jetzt haben wir es und wenn wir
gerade schon dabei sind ich habe durch
zufall noch ein 2015 am modell gefunden
dann aber die playstation 4 slim mit 500
gigabyte für 110 euro das ist verdammt
wenig leider auch schon ausverkauft aber
ich habe halt mehr bezahlt ihr könnt ja
aber kommentieren was wir von den
preisen haltet wir kommen uns noch mal
kurz die bewertungen an 4,6 ist gut
works perfect game also alles auf
englisch ist auf jeden fall nur
positives da hinter mir steht auch schon
eine sache die vielleicht noch gesagt
werden könnte wie herrlich was heißt es
eigentlich wenn man es ins deutsche
übersetzt heißt es eigentlich nur
renoviert also wir haben ja ein produkt
was irgendwo schon mal verwendet wurde
ein fehler hatte oder so dann
zurückgeschickt wurde und von profis
also eigentlich ist es meistens so ich
muss sagen einmal habe ich sie schon
aufgemacht um rein zu gucken weil ich
dann irgendwie mal zu neugierig will
aber was ich super interessant fand ich
weiß nicht ob mir das auch da kann man
erkennen könnt aber wollte ich denke mal
nicht das produkt kommt auf jeden fall
aus großbritannien united kingdom fand
ich sehr interessant weil ich mich sonst
nicht daran erinnern kann dass ihnen
durch produkt mal aus großbritannien kam
irgendwann es immer
so und hier hamburg auch schon meine
neue playstation was sich direkt sagen
muss hier oben das ist einfach also die
verpackung ist halt ein gewissen das ist
halt irgendwie bis hinweg ich glaube
nicht dass es vom transport kommt aber
gut
ich packte jetzt einfach mal aus beim
iphone soll bei der rhi verwischen
iphone das habe ich gar nicht gesagt wo
ist die verpackung da habe ich das für
ihn getan es ist weg juli wo ist das
iphone hier leute ich finde das iphone
ist man schon das war auf jeden fall ein
iphone 4s in einer iphone 6 verpackung
sozusagen also das hat irgendwie auch
nicht so ganz gepasst also ich glaube
wir nehmen wir mal das was so irgendwie
gerade da wir haben jetzt auf jeden fall
die ps4 die an sich also ich muss sagen
bis auf an zwei stellen bisschen dreck
ist nichts dran kein kratzer oder so
finde ich gut vor allem ich find's
klasse von 2015 ist und trotzdem man
sich so gut aussieht
mir egal nachfolgendes machen ich habe
mal versucht die auch zu machen aber ich
lass das besser also bei meiner geht das
ohne probleme wahrscheinlich war das
damals also die geht nicht so leicht
auch als das was sie hier sehen sieht
auf jeden fall nicht schlecht aus muss
ich sagen im controller muss aber auch
dabei seien ja mal noch ein controller
und beschreibung kabel und aber alles
andere finde ich ein bisschen weg also
das wirkt so ein bisschen zusammen
gewürfelt dass es auf französisch
und das hier ist so das ist sogar auf
deutsch irgendwie fehlt aber so eine
haupt beschreibung oder war da nur so
wenig bei also bei der hmi vermischt
iphone hatte ich eigentlich einen sehr
guten eindruck der ist jetzt nicht ganz
so gut also man hätte eigentlich auch
einfach gebraucht schreiben können finde
ich dass unser sport dieses kabel bin
ich mir sicher das wurde schon verwendet
so dass es kein neues kabel was aber an
sich natürlich gar nicht schlimm ist
also ich habe das ein bisschen falsch
rübergebracht ist ja klar dass meistens
die kabel auch nicht nur sind nur das
kabel hat halt von drazan bisher
mitgenommen aussah immer so und hier
wird vielleicht mal rüber geputzt also
kann auch sein dass das ausgetauscht
wurde ich weiß es nicht weil das sieht
wirklich sehr gut aus das eigentlich das
beste hier die playstation gefällt mir
gut
da muss ich sagen der wird auf jeden
fall schon benutzt da sieht man
einiges dran und hier ist auch ein
bisschen dreck drin aber ja ihr seht ja
auch ihr könnt ihr mir eure meinung in
die kommentare schreiben dazu und wir
machen jetzt mal an ich bin mal gespannt
ob die so funktioniert wie ich mir
vorstelle ich wurde dazu jetzt einfach
mal einen alten zocker bildschirm was
mir auch aufgefallen ist hdmi kabel ist
keins dabei das hätte man auch noch dazu
lesen können oder das braucht man nehme
aber gut ich schließe das jetzt mal eben
an und dann sehen wir uns vielleicht
wieder so weit sind mal wenn ich alles
sehe jetzt bin ich mal gespannt ob die
überhaupt angeht netgo bitte gut ja
hdmi-kabel habe ich schon verbunden
jetzt muss es eigentlich losgehen
ajax ist die wild card irgendein update
gemacht oder so ps4 wir auch okay leute
dann jetzt konnte ich auch mal den
controller
das sieht so glaube ich ganz gut aus
abläuft ist ja schon hochgefahren okay
ich hoffe wir können das so gut sehen
wenn er ist natürlich einfach mal
deutsch schnell wer hätte es gedacht
okay jetzt können wir mit wlan connecten
das machen wir doch auch hier könnte mal
sehen so heißt ein wlan netzwerk und das
passwort ist 69 ja also ich wäre
überrascht wenn eben was nicht
funktionieren würde
ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen was ist
jetzt los kamera anschließen
siehst du jetzt die playstation
kameraden das video von der ich will
keine kamera anschließen nachher werde
ich dann auch überwacht ständig über die
playstation pocket zeitzone
ja ok weiter weiter weiter jetzt haben
wir aber die einrichtung in der
playstation ist abgeschlossen erlebe die
welt der unterhaltung viel spaß
dankeschön leute ich muss ganz ehrlich
sagen ich habe keinen plan was ich damit
jetzt machen soll also ihr seht ja
funktioniert wir können auch sicherlich
war eben hier kurs ins internet gehen
oder youtube
[Musik]
ach so ich will jetzt nicht so auf herz
und nieren prüfen ist auf jeden fall an
und bis jetzt mir nichts negatives
aufgefallen ich bin mir sicher da
funktioniert alles was man halten mit
einer playstation machen kann ich selber
habe ja schon eine ps4 deswegen ist
jetzt die frage was machen wir denn mit
der ri verwischt playstation von wish to
play ist ja schon etwas neues ist
deswegen ihr könnt auch wie beim letzten
mal wie beim iphone einfach wieder einen
kommentar schreiben
schreibt einfach mal in die kommentare
was ihr so mit einer ps4 macht zockt ihr
euer lieblingsspiel guckt der youtube
was auch immer also halt sozusagen ihre
haupttätigkeit mit der playstation kann
jeder einfachen kommentar schreiben ihr
müsst nicht nur abonnent sein oder so
wobei ich mich natürlich über jeden
abonnenten feuer so ist ja nicht und das
ist mir genommen da schreibt auch super
gerne in die kommentare welche
rhetorisch fordert zeug noch bestellen
bin ich mal gespannt und dann machen wir
es auf jeden fall noch weil ich finde
super interessant lassen da abonniert
den kanal wir sehen uns mittwoch wieder
um 19 uhr das war's haut rein
[Musik]